hi Lexi how are you good Mario better
than I deserve
what's up I am 24 and he is 35 and we
have two on younger children we are 100%
debt free and we have about almost
$80,000 cash right now and he is looking
into starting like a Roth IRA but we
were just kind of wondering like what
you suggested too because we don't have
a retirement fund started yet okay he
your husband yeah your husband
boyfriend's but almost there's a legal
distinction here okay because it says on
my screen boyfriend and that's why I was
just checking so it because it matters
what you do in that situation so you're
living with your 24 you're living with a
guy that's 35 and you have two little
kids yeah okay all right well the
problem is without marriage you don't
have any rights to anything of his
without a really long and expensive and
bloody lawsuit and vice versa and vice
versa and so if you were married you
could just do his 401k and you would get
half of it if something happened or if
he died you'd get all of it right and
the same thing you could you don't have
to worry about balancing it out but you
don't have a husband you have a roommate
from a legal perspective and so you have
to keep your money running to protect a
24 year old single mom of two because
that's what you are so you have to you
have to do that so I'll just be old ugly
Uncle Dave and tell you what I think cuz
you called my show if I've got a son
that's 26 I have two daughters they're
slightly older than you if one of them
came into my house talking like this I
would say get married for God's sakes to
protect yourself from a legal right yeah
we're looking into doing that later this
year we're engaged but it's just not
there's really no point in delaying
anything here you're already living
together and having babies together I
mean it's not like we planned a big
wedding here Jesus I mean you're already
shacked up so I don't know why we have
to be engaged just go get married for
goodness sakes you're already acting
like you are so anyway but that protects
you kiddo and then you can just go okay
hey we got 80,000 bucks because now we
have $80,000 this $80,000 is it in his
name and the bank account or your name
or both names are what both names are on
the account okay and so what you have
there is what's called a general
partnership and you don't have
partnership agreements and so if he dies
his family will come take half of that
money if they want to that's what I'm
talking about how dangerous this is for
you and for these children so that's why
we just go get married this weekend I
really would and that solves a whole
bunch of your stuff I mean it's not real
romantic but you already decided to do
the whole thing backwards so you know
let's go ahead and take care of business
now and you know get it get her lined up
and let's get going so that's what I
would tell you as your dad or your uncle
or something like that and just to
protect you protect those kids and I'm
not saying your your boyfriend's a bad
guy I'm just and I'm not making a moral
judgment here and it's not the point
we're way past all that I'm trying to
help you not get in a mess because your
money's in pretty good shape if you were
a couple a legal couple so in that case
yes
you've got $80,000 saved that would be
wonderful if you were married you would
carve off part of that call better your
emergency fund you're debt-free that's
wonderful and we would take the rest of
that start thinking about getting our
house if you've already got a house then
we take the rest of that and start talk
about paying off the house and or
funding these kids college so it's baby
steps you would be on baby step four or
five six is where you would be in this
situation
and so Lexie what I want you to hear me
loud and clear is is that you you're in
peril if anything happens between now
and the time you have a marriage license
you're you're you're in peril you're not
going to get what you should be getting
to take care of you and those Joe
and and so and I'm not suggesting
something's going to happen but I've
just dealt with in 35 years of doing
this all the worst case scenarios I'm a
cancer doctor I see what causes cancer
every day and I get to meet with people
like you after they didn't do things
right and have a mess and so please go
fix this soon as possible